>>> FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS IS TRYING TO
WALK BACK EXPLOSIVE CLAIMS HE
MADE IN HIS BOOK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S POSITIVE COVID TEST.
BEFORE WE GET TO HIS DENIAL,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
TIMELINE BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT.
AS WAS FIRST REPORTED IN THE
GUARDIAN, MEADOWS REVEALS IN HIS
SOON TO BE RELEASED MEMOIR, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT FIRST TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID SEPTEMBER
26ICT, THAT WAS THREE DAYS
BEFORE THIS FIRST DEBATE WITH
THEN VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
MEADOWS AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ARE NOW POINTING OUT THAT HE
TESTED NEGTF AFTER TESTING
POSITIVE.
THE SAME DAY, HE HOSTED A WHITE
HOUSE EVENT BOTH INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE FOR THEM SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE AMY CONEY BARRETT, AT
LEAST 12 ATTENDEES LATER TESTED
POSITIVE THERE.
THE NEXT DAY, SEPTEMBER 27th, HE
HOSTED AN INDOOR WHITE HOUSE
RECEPTION FOR GOLD STAR
FAMILIES.
FOLLOWED BY A MASKLESS NEWS
CONFERENCE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING ROOM.
ON SEPTEMBER 29th, WHICH WAS
DEBATE DAY, MEADOWS REPORTS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WAS MOVING
SLOWER THAN USUAL BUT, QUOTE,
NOTHING WAS GOING TO STOP HIM
FROM GOING OUT THERE.
ON OCTOBER 1st, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT FINALLY ACKNOWLEDGES
HE HAD CORONAVIRUS, AND OCTOBER
2nd, HE WAS HOSPITALIZED.
NOW, YESTERDAY, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CALLED THE REPORTING
ON THE CLAIM IN MEADOWS' BOOK
THAT HE TESTED POSITIVE ON
SEPTEMBER 26th FAKE NEWS AND A
FEW HOURS LATER, MEADOWS WNTD ON
NEWSMAX AND SEEMED TO AGREE WITH
HIS FORMER BOSS.
>> I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT SAYS
IT'S FAKE NEWS.
WHAT IS THE STORY HERE?
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
IT'S FAKE NEWS.
IF YOU ACTUALLY READ THE BOOK,
THE CONTEXT OF IT, THAT STORY
OUTLINED A FALSE POSITIVE.
LITERALLY HAD A TEST, HAD TWO
OTHER TESTS AFTER THAT THAT
SHOWED THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE COVID
DURING THE DEBATE.
AND YET, THE WAY THAT THE MEDIA
WANTS TO SPIN IT IS CERTAINLY TO
BE AS NEGATIVE ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN WHILE
GIVING JOE BIDEN A PASS.
>> SO THAT'S TRUE, AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO MEADOWS' ACCOUNT,
THAT IS REPORTEDLY IN THE BOOK,
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT TESTED
NEGATIVE AFTER TESTING POSITIVE.
WHAT MEADOWS DIDN'T SAY THERE
THAT IS REPORTEDLY IN THE BOOK
IS THAT MEADOWS WAS TELLING
EVERYONE IN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S IMMEDIATE CIRCLE TO
TREAT HIM AS IF HE WAS POSITIVE.
MAYBE MEADOWS LEFT THAT PART OUT
OF THE INTERVIEW HE DID WITH
NEWS MAX BECAUSE WHAT OUR GLORIA
BORGER IS LEARNING ABOUT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S REACTION TO
THE REVELATION ABOUT HIS
POSITIVE TEST.
SHE JOINS US NOW ALONG WITH CNN
MEDICAL ANALYST DR. LENA WEN,
AUTHOR OF LIFE LINES, A DOCTOR'S
JOURNEY IN THE FIGHT FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS
DISPUTING WHAT IS REPORTEDLY IN
THE BOOK WRITTEN BY MEADOWS, AND
THAT'S IT, MEADOWS HIMSELF SEEMS
TO AGREE.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING ABOUT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S REACTION
TO ALL THIS?
THERE SO HE AGREES WHAT HE WROTE
WAS FAKE NEWS BECAUSE WE
REPORTED WHAT'S IN THE BOOK
BADLY, AND OF COURSE, THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
WHAT I'M LEARNING IS THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, ACCORDING TO A
SOURCE WHO IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S THINKING, IS THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS FURIOUS
ABOUT WHAT IS IN THE BOOK.
AND THAT HE'S ANGRY WITH MARK
MEADOWS.
NOW, I WAS TOLD BY ONE SOURCE
THAT MEADOWS AND THE PRESIDENT
HAVE NOT HAD A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP.
BUT OTHER SOURCES ARE TELLING
OTHER REPORTERS AT CNN THAT IT
IS A RELATIONSHIP THAT'S BEEN
FINE BECAUSE DON'T FORGET, MARK
MEADOWS IS ON THE TRUMP TRAIN
FOR 2024.
BUT THAT THE PRESIDENT IS MAD
ABOUT THE WAY MEADOWS
CHARACTERIZED ALL OF THIS IN THE
BOOK.
SO WHAT I THINK WE ARE
WITNESSING ON NEWSMAX IS MARK
MEADOWS TRYING TO GET BACK IN
THE PRESIDENT'S GOOD GRACES AND
SAYING, YEAH, BLAME IT ON THE
PRESS.
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO TELL YOU IS
ALL THE PRESIDENT HAD WAS A
FALSE POSITIVE AND THAT'S IT.
AND MOVE ON.
>> BUT GLORIA, WHAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS THE
WHITE HOUSE THEN WENT OUT OF
THEIR WAY, AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, TOO, TO AVOID EVER
ACKNOWLEDGING WHEN HE GOT HIS
FIRST POSITIVE TEST FOR COVID.
IF YOU THINK BACK TO THAT TIME,
THIS WAS A QUESTION OF COULD HE
HAVE POSSIBLY BEEN POSITIVE
DURING THE DEBATE.
>> SURE.
>> HE WOULD NEVER COME FORWARD
AND SAY, YES, I TESTED POSITIVE
ON THIS DATE, YOU KNOW, DAYS
BEFORE.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO GO THERE.
>> YEAH, AND MEADOWS IS ALSO
SAYING THERE WERE THREE TESTS.
WE THINK THERE WERE TWO.
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT ANY KIND OF
THIRD TEST.
WE KNOW THAT THE DEBATE REQUIRED
A NEGATIVE TEST 72 HOURS.
>> RIGHT, AND THE DEBATE
THEMSELVES FOR SOME ODD REASON
DID NOT TEST ON THAT DAY RIGHT
BEFORE THE DEBATE.
I FIND THEM INEXPLUSABLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT ARRIVED LATE.
THERE'S AN HONOR SYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW, THEY OBVIOUSLY
TOLD THE FOLKS THERE, YOU KNOW,
HE HAD TESTED NEGATIVE, SO HE
WENT ON TO THE DEBATE STAGE.
IT WAS, YOU KNOW, THAT WAS THE
SITUATION.
BUT YOU KNOW, THAT'S NOT -- IN
THE EXCERPT OF THE BOOK THAT THE
GUARDIAN PRINTED, AND AGAIN, WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE BOOK.
THAT'S NOT MENTIONED.
>> DR. WEN, JUST IN TERMS OF THE
TIMELINE OF WHEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT STARTED SHOWING
SYMPTOMS AND WAS TAKEN TO WALTER
REED, DOES A POSITIVE TEST ON
OCTOBER 26ICT, AS THE BOOK
REPORTEDLY SAYS TOOK PLACE, DOES
THAT MAKE THE MOST SENSE SINCE
HE WAS HOSPITALIZED ON NOVEMBER
2nd?
>> YES, BECAUSE THE PREVIOUS
TIMELINE MADE NO SENSE TO THOSE
OF US WHO HAVE ACTUALLY TREATED
COVID PATIENTS.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU DON'T GO FROM
ZERO TO 100 OVERNIGHT.
WHAT WE HEARD IS OCTOBER 1st WAS
WHEN FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
FIRST STARTED TESTING POSITIVE.
HE FIRST STARTED HAVING
SYMPTOMS.
THEN BY THE NEXT DAY, HE WAS SO
SEVERELY ILL THAT HE HAD LOW
OXYGEN SATURATION, SUCH
SEVERENESS OF BREATH THAT HE HAD
TO BE AIRLIFTED AND BE IN THE,
CU, BUT AT THE TIME THE CLINICAL
COURSE FOR THE VARIANTS WERE
ABOUT FIVE TO EIGHT DAYS BETWEEN
WHEN YOU FIRST START HAVING
SYMPTOMS TO WHEN YOU FIRST START
HAVING SHORTNESS OF BREATH.
ONE DAY MADE NO SENSE.
SO THIS IS THE REASON WHY SO
MANY OF US WERE ASKING AT THE
TIME, WHEN DID HE TEST POSITIVE,
AND ALSO, WHEN WAS HIS LAST
NEGATIVE TEST?
THERE'S ONE QUESTION THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY I THINK HELP US TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE OF DID PEOPLE
REALLY THINK THIS WAS A FALSE
POSITIVE?
WHICH IS WHEN DID PRESIDENT
TRUMP ACTUALLY GET MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES?
BECAUSE FOR SOMEONE HIS AGE WHO
IS OLDER, WHO HAS CHRONIC
MEDICAL ILLNESSES, WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT, IF HE TESTED POSITIVE
AND HIS MEDICAL TEAM REALLY
BELIEVED HE TESTED POSITIVE,
THEY WOULD HAVE GIVEN HIM
MONOCLONIC ANTIBODIES ON
SEPTEMBER 26th OR SHORTLY
THEREAFTER.
WE KNOW HE GOT THOSE, BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHEN.
FINDING OUTS THAT QUESTION WOULD
HELP US UNDERSTAND DID HIS
MEDICAL TEAM AND THE PRESIDENT
THINK HE REALLY HAD COVID.
>> GLORIA, SO THE GUARDIAN
REPORTED, AS I MENTIONED, IN THE
BOOK, MEADOWS SAYS HE TOLD
PEOPLE IN THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
CIRCLE, QUOTE, SORRY, HE TOLD
PEOPLE IN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S, QUOTE, IMMEDIATE
CIRCLE, TO TREAT HIM AS IF HE
WERE POSITIVE, END QUOTE.
EVEN AFTER THE NEGATIVE TEST,
WHICH OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T -- IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO SQUARE WITH WHAT
MEADOWS IS NOW SAYING, NO, HE
GOT A NEGATIVE TEST OR TWO
NEGATIVE TESTS, AND SO HE WAS
TOTALLY FINE.
IF HE'S TELLING PEOPLE, TREAT
THIS GUY LIKE HE'S POSITIVE,
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT THE THEN
FIRST FAMILY GOING MASKLESS AT
THE DEBATE AND ALSO, I MEAN,
WITH GOLD STAR FAMILIES, FOR
GOODNESS SAKES.
>> RIGHT, IT'S HARD TO PARSE
HERE.
I MEAN, FIRST OF ALL, WHO IS IN
THE PRESIDENT'S INNER CIRCLE?
ISN'T THE FAMILY IN THE
PRESIDENT'S INNER CIRCLE?
AND ALSO, WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
ABOUT CONTACT TRACING AND --
>> WE HAVE SEEN PICTURES OF THE
FAMILY SITTING MASKLESS AT THE
DEBATE, EVEN THOUGH THE
CLEVELAND CLINIC HAD ASKED
EVERYONE TO WEAR MASKS.
>> WEARING A MASK, AND DR. WEN
KNOWS MORE ABOUT THIS THAN I DO,
BUT SHOULDN'TIA BE DOING CONTACT
TRACING WITH PEOPLE WHO WERE IN
IMMEDIATE CONTACT WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
AND I WOULD PRESUME THAT WOULD
MEAN HIS IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
SO HOW -- HOW TO EXPLAIN THE
FACT THAT THEY WOULD GO MASKLESS
IN A PLACE THAT IS ACTUALLY
ASKING PEOPLE TO WEAR MASKS.
IF THEY KNEW THAT HE HAD HAD
EVEN A FALSE POSITIVE AT A
CERTAIN POINT, BECAUSE FROM THE
MOMENT HE GETS A FALSE POSITIVE,
WOULDN'T YOU START SAYING TO
PEOPLE, OKAY, WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT JUST WHO THE PRESIDENT WAS
IN CONTACT WITH.
>> YOU WOULD IF YOU WERE A
DECENT HUMAN BEING OR WITH ANY
SENSE OF SHAME.
ALL THE PEOPLE SITTING THERE WHO
WE JUST SAW ON CAMERA, YOU KNOW,
ERIC TRUMP, DONNY JR., YOU KNOW,
THE WHOLE -- THE WHOLE MISHEGAS
THERE, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
SHAMELESS.
AND CLEARLY, YOU KNOW, WERE
MAKING A VERY PARTICULAR POINT
BY GOING MASKLESS.
DR. WEN, LOOKING BACK ON IT NOW,
IN LIGHT OF THE CLAIMS IN
MEADOWS' BOOK, SHOULD THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OR HIS FAMILY EVEN
HAVE BEEN AT THAT DEBATE?
SHOULDN'T THEY HAVE BEEN
QUARANTINING?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SO TO BE CLEAR, ANYONE, I DON'T
CARE IF IT'S THE PRESIDENT,
FORMER PRESIDENT, OR ANYBODY
ELSE, IF YOU HAVE SYMPTOMS, AND
YOU HAVE A POSITIVE TEST, YOU
SHOULD NOT BE GOING ANYWHERE.
YOU SHOULD BE IN ISOLATION.
ALSO, IF YOU'RE A CLOSE CONTACT,
TO GLORIA'S POINT, IF YOU'RE A
CLOSE CONTACT, AND CERTAINLY
FAMILY WHO LIVE WITH HIM, SHOULD
BE CLOSE CONTACTS, IF YOU ARE A
CLOSE CONTACT OF SOMEBODY WHO
TESTED POSITIVE, YOU SHOULD BE
IN QUARANTINE IF YOU ARE
UNVACCINATED, WHICH THEY WERE AT
THE TIME.
YOU SHOULD NOT BE GOING
ANYWHERE, AND ALSO, YOU SHOULD
NOT BE TEST SHOPPING.
YOU DON'T GET A TEST AND ONCE
IT'S POSIT